hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
still Dave Reuben I've got bree essrig
and whitney mixter and let's roll all
right Anthony Weiner mr. penis on
Twitter he is running for mayor of New
York City he announced it last week and
amazingly he's already second in the
Democratic primary 19% compared to
Christine Quinn's 24% Christine Quinn is
a lesbian by the way which basically
means this whole thing is a referendum
on the penis I think anyway let's take a
look at mr. Weiner's first video and
look I made some big mistakes and I know
I let a lot of people down but I've also
learned some tough lessons I'm running
for mayor cuz I've been fighting for the
middle class and those struggling to
make it my entire life and I hope I get
a second chance to work for you
New York City should be the middle-class
capital of the world and I've got some
ideas on how to do it
sixty-four of them right on my website
take a look tell me what you think we
love this city and no one will work
harder to make it better than Anthony I
will fight for you every single day
thank you for watching okay so there was
a little terror in his wife's face there
but basically I thought it was a pretty
good video and I'm kind of on board the
Weiner train here I think we all sort of
have to forgive him and move on and
there is gonna be stuff of all of us out
there and I think it would be cathartic
for New York and the country if we just
let it go do you guys think that the
penis can get a pass on this
Riu hearse you know I probably should
have read this cuz I thought this whole
thing was about a dachshund named
Anthony but now I mean I loved how he
was sitting in like the cleanest part of
New York like on like the cleanest stoop
yeah well you have to because he can't
be in like a crack den now he's already
associated with sex you can't have him
but does that exist in New York
I plan to yeah Whitney are there clean
sneaky there might be one I haven't
found it yet but you know you did find
it I think the thing here is the the
amount of puns potential funds are
limitless
I mean Weiner comes from me
Quinn is still on top you know I think
the initial closer in the polls but you
know I think I think you know New
Yorkers especially love you know love a
guy that rolls up his sleeves like he
did and when he when he just recently
did the press conference at whatever it
was stands up when he talks you know and
and you can google his [ __ ] yeah they
like like that down-home type so I think
he's got a chance yeah I really though I
really believe that it would be good for
everyone to forgive him like people are
freaking out about you know can we
forgive him and we saw his penis but
don't you think it will actually be good
because this is gonna happen who else
will be able to run for office
ever if we can't forgive this one
because he's just the first you know
when's the last time that happened yeah
I mean you know it just totally bought
it threw me off my game now so continue
please I think it would be good for all
of us like that's the thing that it's
not that I believe in him so much but I
think the idea of a second chance I
always I always like to give people the
benefit of that and I love scandal so
when so happens I'm just like yes yeah
you yes you will make headlines you will
make things funnier so I think and as a
performer that's really what you were so
this isn't about you don't live in New
York so it's not about being a
constituent does my is my opinion even
valid no
we do more SNL skits about it sure
that's all I care about so I mean it's
and the scandal he at least he did it
before he got into office you know so
it's like oh I got that out of the way
you know yeah so you know what kudos to
you Anthony Weiner yeah don't you guys
think though it's possible that he'll
actually have to be an honest politician
because of this like he already is done
saying that is so scandalous like it
doesn't get much more scandalous than
the penis like he'd have to be honest
now which most politicians have to be
the reverse is a great point yeah so I
sound like
three people backing Anthony Wiener none
of us live in New York anymore that's
true wait okay maybe I'm confused
yeah is he gay no okay he's married yeah
you really want now let's start another
scandal oh yes gay gay I wanted to throw
that out there I want to start the rumor
that nice day yay then why was he then
who's that woman he's sitting on the
stoop with an actress just so very she'd
be regretful yeah what do you think
about the wife though cuz she always
looks like she's just like I mean I'm
already in this deep I might as well
just finish our first ride you know like
it's like oh yeah
she just has this look of I'm just tired
yeah but you know he he was fairly well
undead so maybe that's my enemy he's
right that's why she what he's running
and he's running against the lesbian
krislac quick why are we not voting for
her why are we not yes why why are we
giving him a second chance of not voting
for her I like Christina I do like
Christine Quinn she's really really good
voting for him right now and then but
now that I think about it I kind of
don't want to and I kind of want you
yeah
does a lesbian have to vote for another
lesbian as a general rule of thumb it's
like pretty much you gotta vote for
those I think it's just more just like
women have to vote for women it's yeah
that's what I feel like I mean
especially I don't know I just
especially okay and I just I don't want
to be a hypocrite girl just that I would
give him a second chance but he does
have all this baggage yeah College Wow
yeah your change is pretty quick I just
did yeah yeah now that I think about it
I don't know although that commercial or
that little promo he made that was
really wonderful yeah well did you guys
hear that in that promo the beginning
shot actually was in Pittsburgh or
something that was anyway yeah and then
the image on his website on Anthony
Weiner dot-com of course there's an
image from yeah
I think he should have like gone with
like another pun to and he's like
there's all 64 of them on my website
it's like just stick with the theme and
be like there's 69 I'm out you know do
you think we're ever gonna have a
politician that we're not going to see
his genitals in the future like it seems
to me that you know what do you mean
like anyone that's of a certain age now
this stuff is just out there the webcam
is on everyone's computer that's why I
feel like we have to forgive him for
this because other and also what does
politics have to do with morals like I
feel like a penis pics every politics
morals know what do they have to do with
so right Yeah right about that that's
why it seems to me that like when he's
sitting there on the stoop with his wife
and they look so happy it's like you
know what she doesn't have to be that
happy she could just be like I'm
sticking with this guy and his frickin
wiener but all right well I don't know
that we got any votes for wiener there
we might have helped Christine Quinn and
that's just the Democratic primary so
you know they're gonna run against the
Republican so we'll see what